mesdames et messieurs pour la suite de
ce thé dicks spécial écologie
réchauffement climatique je vous demande
d'applaudir dimitru
dimitri
du traict dimitri
je suis désolé marine âgée qui fera
soucis avec mon véhicule électrique il
est tombé en panne à deux kilomètres je
suis vraiment désolé intrigue
je suis désolé j'arrête pas d'avoir des
ennuis depuis lundi si l'horreur
enfin faut absolument que je vous
raconte en fait j'ai acheté un véhicule
électrique pour remplacer mon véhicule
hybride
donc ce lundi
je rentre avec eux donc mon véhicule
électrique tout content donc je reviens
chez moi et donc je remets à charger et
puis je me prépare un petit repas
je m'installe dans le canapé je regarde
une petite série sympathique que j'aime
beaucoup et puis bon bah je regarde
je regarde l'horloge et les 22h37 qui
pâtissent mais
la
réunion de nos
croyances une deuxième fois qu'est ce
qui se passe dans google
wave ou ferrals mais vous êtes fini là
il ya plus de lumière
à
[Applaudissements]
évin je peux vous dire que
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
l'indien parce que en fait donc bah je
regardais ma série comme je vous disais
un pays bas après ben plus d'électricité
est d'ailleurs en fait ce qu'il sait
même passé c'est que même pas pu
recharger rita blement véhicules
électriques en voyez un peu le problème
bon vous comprenez pourquoi je suis
arrivé en retard bon alors où est ce que
j'en étais encore ah oui donc 22h37 non
pas qu d'électricité un bail et 22h37 je
me dis mais y'a pas grand chose à faire
et qu'est ce que je vais faire donc
c'est pas mal je vais aller me coucher
très bien
je me dis bon allez demain il y aura
l'électricité d'ici là jamais à
recharger mon portable pas de problème
je peux l'avouer il fait un petit peu
frisquet donc je me mets sous la couette
je m'endors
il bon je me réveille le lendemain matin
je regarde mon téléphone
7h17
7% de batterie
toujours pas d'électricité
on va écouter
je prends une douche froide évidemment
on chauffe eau bas il n'a pas chauffée
durant la nuit donc bon je vais dans la
cuisine je prends le pain mou je l'avais
laissée dans le congélateur la veille il
va falloir que je mette tout à la
poubelle je sors de chez moi je me dis
bon allez je valais le boulangerie et là
je vois quelques badauds qui sont là
avec le chargeur à la main près de chez
mon voisin parce que ben il a été malin
en fait il a installé des panneaux
photovoltaïques ok bon je prends j'en
prends mon vélo j'enfourche et là je
roule à toute vitesse vers la
boulangerie et vieille boulangerie
fermait bain et puis d'électricité c'est
normal on s'aperçoit là des agents
municipaux qui sont là avec une feuille
de papier griffonné à la main genre non
mais qu'est ce qui se passe bon vieux
temps de la feuille de papier j'apprends
panne d'électricité générale dans tout
le département
électricité entre 16 heures et 18 heures
aujourd'hui et demain
dette de rétablissement inconnu
vous pensez que ça ne peut pas arriver
ça arrive déjà ça arrive au pakistan au
liban à new york vous savez quoi ça a
même failli arriver dans toute l'europe
louis janvier dernier oui le 8 janvier
dernier
en fait on a dû
déconnecté seize grands sites
industriels en france et d'autre en
italie pour éviter le black out général
elle n'arrive pas que pour l'électricité
vous savez non
les ruptures d'approvisionnement les
hausses brutales de prix ça arrive pour
les fruits et légumes ça arrive pour les
composants électroniques vous êtes
attend entendu parler aussi un pour le
blé dur on a les pattes ça coûte plus
cher et peut-être même
peut-être que même que
pour les jouer
eh bien il va falloir faire une croix
dessus le jour de noël
nous vivions dans un monde d'abondance
bienvenue dans le monde de la rareté
bienvenue dans un monde où la
consommation gogo n'est plus tenable
parce que ben
on n'a plus les ressources pour
l'alimenter
bienvenue dans un monde où
va falloir choisir entre regarder une
série en 5 j où aller se faire cuire un
oeuf
bienvenue dans un monde où nous sommes
tirés une balle dans le pied
à force d'une croissance à tout prix un
qui a déréglé notre climat et dessiner
notre biodiversité
alors c'est vrai nous ne nous sommes pas
préparés à ce monde-là enfin soyons
francs alors évidemment on peut faire
l'autruche on préfère faire l'autruche
évidemment ces musiques pourtant si on
se pose des questions à l'avance
et bien
on peut chercher et trouver les réponses
et d'ailleurs même vous
vous pouvez les poser à vos voisins vos
proches à vos collègues de travail avant
élu et je pense que vous pourriez même
beaucoup plus facilement trouver des
solutions
parlons maintenant des entreprises
avec nos casquettes de consommateurs et
notre carte de crédit en fait on peut
les inciter à
proposer
des produits qui fonctionnent sans
électricité des produits qui en fait
sont faciles à réutiliser ou facile à
réparer un
loyer mais
si les entreprises cessent de vendre les
produits neufs commencent à le faire
pour survivre
c'est une bonne question
j'ai une idée vous savez les entreprises
principalement ont un modèle économique
linéaire alors on produit ensuite on
consomme qu'après on jette
ici les entreprises basculer un modèle
économique circulaire en fait ce qu'elle
frères séquelles concevrait des produits
pour qu'ils puissent durer plus
longtemps pour qu'ils puissent est
facile à réutiliser qu'ils puissent être
facile à réparer en dernier ressort
faciles à recycler
et pourrait même proposer des
services justement ces services là pour
bâtir un modèle économique et gagner de
l'argent
ouais mais
ça coûtait trop cher fallait les gens
vont pas acheter ce type de produits pas
nécessairement non non il imaginait que
vous souhaitiez acheter une veste au
rebond première option un facile en ce
qu'on fait tous parce qu'on faisait tous
c'est
à prendre une
baisse de la fast fashion de la mode
éphémère à 40 euros alors bon évidemment
on utilise quatre fois et puis pouf
poubelles passé n'a pas de bol c'est pas
recyclables ah bon deuxième option vous
acheter une veste à 120 euros ah ouais
j'ai tellement elle est plus chère mais
durent plus longtemps et en plus vous
savez que vous pourrez la revendre à 100
euros quelle option choisir yevou
peut-être la deuxième alors il ya un
autre intérêt pour les entreprises je
pense que vous n a entendu parler on en
entend parler y ait beaucoup dans les
journaux ces temps ci
est quand même pas mal d'entreprises 1
qui font face à des pénuries alors chez
les semi conducteurs des matières
premières
puis après aussi les hausses de prix un
donneur j de transport maritime
et si en fait elle bascule sur un modèle
économique circulaire et bien en fait
elle pourrait dégager des revenus
complémentaires qui pourraient alors
partiellement mais compensé leur
chute de ventes
et même en fait elles pourraient ainsi
d'un
payer notamment leurs salariés leurs
fournisseurs
elle pourrait même créer d'ailleurs des
emplois locaux 1 plutôt qu'à des
milliers de kilomètres
et puis
non seulement ça mais si elles
travaillent ensemble et coopèrent
ensemble
alpe elles peuvent créer des filières
basque on l'appelle d'économie
circulaire locales 1 donc c'est au
bénéfice de tous localement
alors c'est vrai
mais est ce que les actions nos actions
tant qu'individu et les actions en tant
qu'entreprise suffisent
non
non non ça suffit pas pour transformer
une société en nous transforme doucement
de société qu'ils soient moins
vulnérables
qui soit aussi on dit plus résiliente au
changement climatique
je prenons un exemple vous souvenez de d
inondation de la vallée de la roya ya il
ya un an se sont pas complètement sorti
d'ailleurs
imaginer pas une aide de
2,5 10 inondation de la vallée de la
roya en france en même temps
est-ce que vous pensez que l'état cela
sera à même de pouvoir voir voler au
secours de tous les territoires
je n'en suis pas sûr
est-ce qu'il serait capable de tout
reconstruire d'un coup de baguette
magique
je suis pas sûr
en fait pour rendre une société
résiliente pour rendre une société
s'adapte justement au changement
climatique il faut mettre les
territoires au centre et pas sur les
côtés
c'est ce que j'appelle une société boule
de gui la boule de dire donc vous voyez
la boule de gui qu'on voit notamment
dans l'est dans les peupliers parfois
dans les chaînes aussi un bon
quand on regarde par exemple qu'une
boule de gui en fait elle l'a déçu
sentent qu'ils vont prélever de la sève
donc de larmes qui vont ensuite
permettre de développer de la
chlorophylle ou développé par un ensuite
donc des feuilles pour poursuivant
l'analogie on a cette boule de gui et
puis parce qu'on peut se dire c'est
comme chaque baie représente en fait un
territoire bon et après chaque tige
qu'il y a entre les baies représentent
les relations de coopération dans trade
entre les différents territoires et puis
après voyez les branches qu'on a là et
puis le tronc représente l'organe
central savait par exemple l'état qui
peut d'ailleurs soutenir les territoires
après évidemment vous allez me dire mais
ok mais pourquoi une société boule de
gui serait plus résiliente on serait
capable de s'adapter au changement
climatique plutôt qu'au mieux que la
société actuelle en fait dans une
société boule de gui les territoires
acquiert un
premier niveau d'autonomie
et donc ils sont capables d'offrir un
filet de sécurité à la fois aux
habitants aux entreprises et aussi aux
acteurs publics alors ça dans plein de
domaines différents il ya le domaine de
l'énergie ale domaine de l'alimentation
de l'eau de la santé aussi un on peut
avoir aussi bien des panneaux
photovoltaïques qui sont partagés comme
solution peut avoir des ceintures
maraîchères aussi qui sont autour de la
ville et sa sonde certain nombre de
solutions
l'objectif n'est pas que ces territoires
soient 100% autonome
parce qu'elles n'ont pas les ressources
pour pouvoir le l'être d'ailleurs en
fait pour être tout à fait honnête même
les territoires n'aurait pas leurs
ressources pour être vraiment résilient
elles ont besoin de l'état ou des
régions évidemment les hentais les
régions peuvent financer mais ça suffit
pas l'état les régions peuvent aussi
apporter à la fois d un cap des
orientations qu'ils soient claires et
aussi apporter des formations des
solutions aux la fois bien sûr aux
agents aux administrations qui sont bien
sûr sur le territoire et l'état et les
régions peuvent aussi aider à mutualiser
les solutions et les ressources entre
les différents territoires et faciliter
la coopération pour éviter évidemment de
réinventer la roue c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous invite toutes et tous à
dès aujourd'hui et pas demain je dis
bien dès aujourd'hui et pas demain à la
fois
anticipé agir
coopérer pour bâtir ensemble une société
boule de gui qu'ils soient plus qu'ils
s'adaptent plus aux changements
climatiques soient plus résiliente et
enfin et ça c'est extrêmement important
qui bénéficiera bien sûr à toutes et à
tous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]